welcome to Simply learn a career in
cyber security is dynamic and in high
demand it offers diverse path from
penetration testing to risk management
continuous learning is crucial due to
evolving threats ethical responsibility
is Paramount you will tackle Global
challenges and certifications like cissp
and ceh can boost your prospects it
offers competitive salaries job security
and also ethical considerations
networking and cyber security Community
is wider overall it's a rewarding field
for Tech enthusiasts who want to protect
digital assets in this video cyber
security professional ansh babnani with
over two plus years of work experience
in application Security will take you
through the complete cyber security
roadmap for 2024 join us as Ange one of
the India's top content creator will
take you through the top salaries taken
in the cyber security field and we will
wrap up this video with of cyber
security certification to look out in
2024 as trusted by ansh don't miss out
on this valuable resource designed
specifically for aspiring cyber experts
presented by ansh pabnani over to ansh
hey have you heard about Twitter's data
breach employees that are getting leaked
have you heard about last fast data
getting breached have you heard about
Facebook getting hacked there are so
many news that we hear day in and day
out in this world and they are so common
in recent times we all know how big is
the scope of cyber security and it's
increasing day by day statistics show
that over 1 million job openings will be
there by the end of 2023 and the fact is
less than 50 percent of individuals are
actually skilled to do the job less than
50 percent and even after the Advent of
AI it's the same as digitization
increases more and more people are
coming online more and more businesses
are doing their business online coming
up with their assets online after covet
there is 600 percent increase in cyber
attacks and I'm not kidding and there is
a big fact check that every 38 seconds
there is a targeted Cyber attack
happening somewhere in the world so what
is cyber security cyber security is an
industry where we apply techniques and
tools used to protect a computer-related
system namely software Hardware or a
network from cyber criminals or hackers
and honestly cyber security as a whole
is a very huge field when people say
about I'm getting a job in cyber
security how to get a job in cyber
security there is no job in cyber
security as such you won't get it there
are many fields there are many
disciplines many domains inside that so
you need to get a job inside that
because there are so many systems
diverse systems that have their own life
cycle to secure for example you might
have heard about different types of
softwares namely web applications mobile
applications maybe Android or iOS
desktop applications iot applications
and many more for a job in cyber
security you can be a destroyer or a
protector you can join both the sides of
the the coin for an offensive job you
hack and find bugs for a defensive job
you identify attacks and stop them and
this is a very high level simplification
of a cyber security job even if you go
inside red team and blue team there are
so many different domains like namely
appsec Cloud SEC forensic investigator
SOC iot malware analyst incident
responder and so on and the most common
jobs you might have heard about in cyber
security are pen tester for offensive
jobs vapt or red team and for defensive
job it's SOC SOC analyst or a DFI
analyst or a blue teamer and if I go in
deep on all the domains will be out of
scope for this video I'm here to give
you a general overview of every domain
and how to create a career potentially
out of that and I'll give you a roadmap
for the exact things that you will do
and you should do I cannot tell you
exactly what to do because there is no
perfect roadmap for anything but I'll
just give you the bare minimums and my
recommendations what I would suggest you
to do so let's get started but one
problem I want to tell you that I can
tell you what to learn and how to learn
it but you'll need to find the resources
to learn because they're very scattered
there is no single course that can teach
you everything so the problem with
people is that they'll go there they'll
find resources on Google they'll learn
from scattered resources and the problem
will be that they will not have complete
knowledge of the same domain in deep
they'll pick up voids between their
knowledge so it will affect their career
but what if someone shows you the exact
things to learn and make your industry
ready for a domain I'm gonna talk about
simply learns industry ready cyber
security program that will teach you
in-demand skills in just six months and
your career can be started right away
this program is Advanced executive
program in cyber security by simply
learn in collaboration with triple RT
Bangalore where you will learn this
in-demand skills from their top faculty
with real world scenarios and here you
will learn practical knowledge by
solving practical Labs with popular
tools including necessary sand burp
Suite after the completion of your
course you will get a completion
certificate from triple it Bangalore and
a transcript to validate your learning
apart from that you will get a virtual
internship from npci National payments
Corporation of India in which you will
get four projects where you will have to
solve cyber security problems by
identifying issues or vulnerabilities in
a system and tell how to secure them
sounds exciting right so if you want to
be eligible for this program you need to
have a bachelor's degree at least and
one year work experience in any relevant
security field and some basic knowledge
of programming so if you are interested
then link is in the description go to
the link read all the description and
all the details click on apply now fill
all your details and just enroll right
away in order to learn cyber security
you need to First learn some
prerequisites it's not that easy to jump
directly into that so first of all you
need to love computers you need to fall
in love with them I am serious so first
of all the very basic skill you need to
learn is computer fundament angles so I
O input output software Hardware how
memory management is done Disk
Management memory Process Management
Windows and Linux in both the OS and I'm
not kidding you need to learn system
administration level of courses you can
do a plus and then you need to learn
virtualization too how to run an OS over
OS and multiple OS and you can find all
those courses on YouTube you don't have
to wander around anywhere and waste your
time everything you can get free so the
next thing that you need to learn is the
most important thing they want to talk
about is computer networking so that's
the most important thing no single
computer can be hacked if it's not
connected to anything else so there is
no isolated system in cyber security so
you need to learn how computers are
connected the basic TCP IP and OSI
models and all the layers inside that
the most important layers are data link
layer till the application layer so the
application layer is most important here
all the protocols that you will learn
HTTP SMTP FTP SSH and Android thing the
most common in web is HTTP so you need
to be thorough inside that that is
indirectly related to internet internet
runs on IP addresses and port numbers so
the third and fourth layer are very
important for you to understand how
network works if you want to be a
network pen tester then IP IP layers and
IP protocols and IP types I had a
formats TCP UDP port numbers and all the
details inside that and I'll repeat
again 90 of hacking is based on network
so you need to learn them you can learn
from books there is some good book I can
recommend data communication and
networking from photosyn that I
personally used but you can watch
YouTube videos you can watch courses and
I'll repeat again 90 of hacking is based
on network so internet is networking the
third thing is Linux and shell
programming if you don't know majority
of world's servers are based out of
Linux because it's robust some examples
for robust Linux servers are rhel and
send OS and even after that the
attacking machine that most of the
hackers use in the world is based out of
Linux because Linux is open source Linux
is robust it's customizable so you know
everything about it and you need to be
learning shell programming because even
if you don't have any tools with guis
you'll need to learn how to use them on
command line it's very important because
as a hacker you might have seen that
command line window a black screen or a
crane text so that's very fancy right
that is what is terminal or a shell you
need to learn that to be cool just
kidding learning Linux is very easy you
can start from a beginner friendly OS
like Ubuntu it's very easy to learn you
can just explore and try things there
learn tools and then you can switch to a
hacker OS called Kali you might have
heard about it right many things so then
you can learn how to use tools because
it's made for penetration testers bio
pen testers and there are many tools you
can you can Master you can learn the
techniques of hacking and it will be
very cool but first you need to make
sure that you're doing things right and
ethically and by shell programming in
Linux I mean Bash that's the the current
standard of shell being used so there
are lot of commands many simple commands
once you keep typing you'll remember in
your subconscious mind lscd vwd CP all
of these commands will be used in your
daily basis and the next thing is
programming do we need to learn
programming many people ask me this
question is there a need I don't know
how to code I'm very weak in that but
I'll tell you if you opt for a offensive
job in a pen testing world you need to
learn how to program and how code is
written because in a corporate world
there is white box pen testing you get
access to the source code so you have to
extensively review the source code and
then find issues in that so there is no
way out eventually you'll need to learn
it but at the starting for a beginner I
won't say it's a big deal or a big
headache to conquer but you can keep it
on hold for some time just familiarize
yourself with cyber security concept and
once you feel you are ready to learn
programming on the site along the way
then you can just start it because
eventually you'll need to learn it at
the end so why not start early so it's a
very simple concept right how a software
is made what is it made of gold right so
if you need to hack a software you need
to learn how it is coded how it is
written so you need to learn to read
code so you need to learn many basic
concepts of programming like data types
variables uh conditionals Loops classes
and objects and these are enough so
these are the major Concepts that you
need to learn in basic programming and
you can pick up any programming language
that you can Master but you don't know
which programming language will come
before you to hack or test it can be
anything so you have to learn the basic
concept the syntax are different in all
the languages but the basic concept is
same so these are the prerequisites that
I will recommend you to learn at the
bare minimum and these are very crucial
so once you get through all of them and
do brainstorming and keep everything in
mind and you've learned everything then
you can start go learn cyber security
from various sources because they're
very scattered and even then there is no
single course of cyber security there
are many domains many disciplines and
each of them have different things to
learn and topics and even here I have a
bare minimum concept to learn for you
all is the WASP top 10. so what is wasp
was is a foundation of web security that
is developed and designed for web
developers and security researchers to
make them aware about cyber attacks and
how they can secure themselves and every
three or four years they will release an
extensive list of top 10 vulnerabilities
or attacks that is the result of
consensus of all the issues and attacks
reported recently through statistics and
they have extensive resource Factory for
all of them including labs and tools and
they are all free so if you see the list
you will see some examples like Access
Control security misconfiguration secure
design ssrf I'm not going to take all
the names but for each attack type they
have their own descriptive documentation
they'll make you understand as a hacker
and all also as a developer how you can
see how we can identify the issue in
your code and how you can fix them
optimally and even for all the issues
there are Labs that you can solve to
practice them and realize them in real
world they have many Labs including a
wasp Juice Shop believe app you can just
set up them on a local machine or just
run a cloud instance and then just
practice them and even they conduct
conferences by the name of Coast they
also have their YouTube Pages you can
learn from them and they have a lot of
documentation they have a two low ASP
Zap for pen testing just like burp Suite
so they have very good resources and
I'll tell you one thing that practice is
the key if you learn a concept today
don't just leave it like that the theory
won't help you in getting a job you need
to practice the concept each and every
attack issue framework volatility you
need to practice them on your own
Hands-On with your own Labs so I'll tell
you that you know already that how
technology changes drastically every day
so you need to get updated and be
proactive are learning new things this
is a complete practical field okay and
then there is another resource just like
wasps there is another resource called
ports rigger they have their own Labs
called Web Security Academy where you
can learn all the concepts of web
security and solve the labs online which
are free and also they have a tool
called burp Suite that's the most
popular tool that every hacker uses when
they want to pen test something so even
I use that even you will use that
everyone uses that and every Cyber
attack has an impact and a risk involved
in that and there is a huge difference
between risk and impact that's where our
risk and compliance teams come into
place the risk management there is a
different job profile called GRC or
governance risk and compliance with many
other names but the concept is the same
that you find an issue but how to fix
that and how to fix the risk the risk is
associated to the business the risk and
compliance team will relate every risk
to the business impact or objective so
the basic goal of cyber security is is
to identify and realize your risk and
then to contain it and reduces as much
as possible that's where hacker come in
to realize those risks and if I talk
about defensive jobs their job is to
learn digital forensics and incidents so
they need to learn how to do Incident
Management how to review the locks how
to use Siem tools and how to correlate
data so they'll have to find evidences
of all the attacks that recently
happened and continuously monitor the
network events and create alerts so that
they can respond to them so they have to
do a lot of Investigation correlation
and Road cost analysis of the issue once
they find the root or the culprit
they'll try to reduce the risk and
prevent that from happening in the
future so likewise we have many domains
and each domain has its own deep
knowledge that you cannot gain that's
not possible you need to select a domain
of your choice that you can only get by
research by self-study no College can
teach you that but I'll tell you one
more problem I told you everything that
you need to learn one you learn
everything you gain all the skills you
do a lot of practice that you know that
you know everything that you can do and
perform those attacks but how will you
tell the HR how will the HR know so it's
not just about acquiring skills it's
also about proving your skills that's
what happens when you look for a job
when you hunt a job look for a good
career the first thing is to build your
resume professionally that's the short
listing criteria you won't even get to
the interviews if you don't take this
seriously so I'll tell you what all
things you'll need to add in your resume
so the first thing is degree
unfortunately you need to do a degree in
CS or it Branch because most companies
want that and my preference for a degree
is B Tech then BCA and then be SC but if
you are a math student the b-tech is the
best option if you are an art student
then you don't have any choice you can
do BC or BSC if you are from any other
Branch like electrical mechanical civil
you haven't done bachelors in CS or it
then you can go for Masters you should
go for Masters but I won't say it's very
hard requirement or a very necessary
thing to do I didn't do Masters myself
but if you want you can do that it will
be a good option for a job if you're
getting good placements in that college
but I'll tell you that the degree is the
only thing that we require we don't care
about anything else and how you do it
you just need that certificate so you
can do private programs distant learning
anything doesn't matter the second thing
is projects they are very important as a
fresher especially because you don't
have any work experience so you need to
do something apart from your learning so
whatever you learned whatever skills you
gained you should apply them somewhere
to prove it like that's the point so you
can apply our cyber security skills with
any other domain like AI Cloud security
blockchain web 3 include anything
combine them and create a good project
with many project ideas that I can give
you and then you need to open source
that because you need to show the
employer because they will demand and
require your link that they can verify
themselves because there are many false
alarms out there and I've already told
you how you can do projects in cyber
security the simply learn internship
from mpci from that advanced executive
program will give you four projects
that's all you need that's all you need
to put so you can put that link in your
resume along with your LinkedIn that's
equally important and the next thing is
certifications and I'll tell you that if
you do a certification and you don't
need to do a master's degree at all it's
not required do some good certifications
because they teach you a skill in a
particular niche in deep in a shorter
time so it won't take you two years it
will just take you one month two months
three months or maximum six months if
you are good enough and there are many
certifications right now in the market
that you can choose but for India for an
HR I think ceh is the most basic
certification that they look because
they all know that but skill wise eh is
not good it's just a theory Examination
for practical skills for actual skill
development you should give oscp because
as HR love set and also you'll get a
better job with a better salary and a
better company with oscp because it's
more skillful and more better than ceh
holder and also the problem is with oscp
is the price that's why not many people
take it it's more costly but if you want
to be cheaper and gain some practical
skills too you can do e-learn
certifications like ejpt ecppt or eccpt
you can correct me ewaptx those are very
practical and very good certifications
not on the level of oscp very close to
them but still they are cheaper so it's
a good deal there are about
certifications that are more relevant in
outside countries like Security Plus pen
Test Plus crtp so that you can do that
if you want to plan for some foreign
countries or foreign jobs so likewise
two three certifications are more than
enough and now comes work experience the
internship I've already told you how to
get an internship just go to the simply
lens program and you will get it just
enroll there so that's not a problem for
you but if you want extra internships
you'll go to the the LinkedIn create an
account today you'll need to be actively
involved in LinkedIn and don't use any
other social media more than LinkedIn
because it's going to help you in your
job search the most so connect with
people do an internship at least three
months or maybe six months that will
gain you a good experience on how work
is done in an industry and then even
that company itself can give you a job
offer called PPO and you can join with a
good package or a salary so now your
resume is strong enough you can actively
look for jobs and that too it will be
the same in LinkedIn so you need to
build as much connections as possible
with good people working in a good
company in your desired cyber security
domain connect with HRS and approach
them talk to them personally share your
resume be professional be polite be kind
and make sure that you reveal a sense of
passion inside you and building a good
Network in LinkedIn helps a lot you will
get a lot of referrals if possible if
you don't know what referral is if you
you can just get into a company with a
trust of another person that's already
working in that company and getting a
referral makes your job hunt much easier
you land a job much easier because
you'll get interviews and even if you
make some mistakes in your interviews it
will be a trust Factor they will be
tolerable and they'll select you and for
a job hunt I have seen people talking to
me coming back saying that they are not
getting a job they have tried hard
enough but when I ask them how many
companies you have applied on they say
only five or ten that doesn't make sense
you need to apply at least 50 to 100
companies because the average reward
rate is 10 so if you apply in 50
companies you will get reply from five
of them so that's the rate and keep that
in mind try hard as you can so when your
resume is shortlisted you'll have three
to four technical rounds with a
managerial round these are the average
figures and if you are applying for an
offensive job like a pen tester you'll
get you'll expect wasp top 10 and code
review questions definitely and scenario
based questions are very common and good
companies today because they'll have to
test you on a hypothetical situation how
you handle the situation what is the
decision-making approach and how you
solve the problems in very stressful
environment how you can work under
stress and don't even lose your
composure and calm in those situations
so the technical skills are not enough
you need to have some soft skills like
communication skills listening skills
decision making skills and always have a
growth mindset I'll tell you one simple
key to getting a job in cyber security
is to understand the risk of your assets
and learn how to contain them and adapt
to the ever evolving and changing threat
landscape cyber security is an
ever-evolving field its scope is not
going to get declined anytime soon it
will just keep improving so the only
problem with people is that they don't
learn consistently so you need to learn
consistently and be aware of all the
technological updates around you and you
should be good I'll keep talking about
the enormous scope of cyber security and
all the lucrative job offers inside that
but I'll keep getting this one question
and it's quite obvious why will you do a
job apart from all the other reasons
there is one reason that stands first
and that is money and there is a lot of
money in cyber security honestly I'm not
exaggerating but many people won't
believe me because they will expect
blacks of packages as a fresher
everything takes time and if you are
consistent if you have the right skill
set no one is stopping you from earning
millions or even lacks per month so gear
up for this video as I will be sharing
the top 5 most popular job profiles in
cyber security and what are their
packages and salaries in India as well
as abroad for freshers as well as
experienced so let's get started first
of all this list is not in any order
these are the top five profiles that are
trending right now and will only boom in
the future and also the figures I will
tell you will be your fixed base pay the
concept of CTC involves a lot of stock
Holdings other benefits in the number so
I'll be telling you just what you will
get in your monthly paycheck excluding
taxes number one penetration testers
these people are also called by the name
of security analyst security Engineers
based on the job profile and Company but
to give you a clear idea these people
proactively identify threats and issues
in an organization's critical
infrastructure both in their software
and Hardware products to let the owner
know and fix the issues appropriately
and they are immensely important to any
ID dependent business and companies are
slowly realizing their worth and
increasing their pay but getting hard as
a fresher here it's a bit tricky because
this is a skill heavy job to talk about
salaries in India as a fresher you can
get six to seven LPA in the starting
this will also include your training
budget and other benefits you can do any
certification from a popular vendor such
as offensive security EC Council or Sans
and also you get chance to visit and
attend offline conferences namely nelcon
besides orasp even Defcon and black hat
if you get some experience of two three
years your salary can jump to 12 to 15
LPA but if you keep working for five or
more years your salary may even go up to
25 to 30 LPA if I talk about foreign
countries when you get paid in dollars
your salary can be 100K dollars per year
when you start and if you keep working
for five plus years of experience your
salary can go to 160 to 180k per year
these people are also called red teamers
by the way speaking of red teaming these
jobs are really very difficult because
the people here are really not competent
and red teaming requires immense
creativity and deep conceptual knowledge
of the whole network stack so learning
pen testing is not very easy but I can
make you skillful enough with a guided
course that can even give you a
professional certificate from IIT kanpur
I'm talking about simply learns
professional certificate program in
cyber security red teaming in which you
will be taught by expert faculties from
IIT kanpur this program is an online
boot camp which runs for six months in
which you will be taught by industry
experts how to identify and analyze
threats at scale and how to create
strategies to secure systems through
Hands-On training in real world cases
you will also get a chance to attend
live sessions in latest AI Trends and
also generative Ai and llms this will
teach you the most popular red teaming
tools used and also help you to develop
a hacker's mindset and also you can
manage threats and overall security
posture of an organization at the end
you will be getting three industry
projects where you will do real world
malability assessments on real world
targets and which will help you to
Showcase your skill set to your future
employers and also not to forget you
will get a professional certificate from
IIT kanpur as well simply learn also
provides you job assistance so that you
can land your dream job the hiring
network is right in front of you some
big names you already thought of so to
be eligible for this program you should
have at least one bachelor's degree in a
tech field you should have basics of
programming and cyber security skills
and not required but if you have one or
two years of professional work
experience that will be better
application is really very simple just
go to the description click on the link
review all the program details click on
apply now and then ask you some details
fill all the details required and just
submit and wait for the revert back and
believe me there are not many good
programs that will teach you so much in
so less so don't think wise just get
started number two security analyst
these are the blue teamers they are also
called by the name sock analyst cyber
security analyst forensic analyst and
these people are constantly watching out
for real-time threats so that they can
alert and prevent them from causing any
harm and they are the first line of
defense of any infosec department and
this is the reason why they are required
in any info Department even when they
don't have proactive pen testers they
will definitely have blue teamers
because they are the first one to be
hired they are defensive in nature if I
talk about salaries in India as a
fresher you can get five to seven LPA
for two to three years of experience you
can get 10 to 15 LPA and for five plus
years of experience you can go up to 20
to 25 LPA in U.S these people are paid
slightly less than the pen testers they
can start from 100K per year and they
can go up to 150 to 170k in five plus
years of XP number three cyber security
manager they are in very high demand
right now because organizations are
investing huge money in security
infrastructure because everyone knows
how important is data today just like
software development teams have project
managers we have security managers so
they decide the plan of action for I.T
issues and data breaches and they create
policies for secure functioning of I.T
assets and they also onboard and manage
security projects and delegate them to
the team members rightfully and help
maintain the overall security posture
and of course you cannot be hired as a
manager right away you need to have at
least five years of experience in a
security domain and then you can be
starting as a manager for starting of
course the salaries are very high in
India these people start from 15 to 20
LPA and they can even go to 30 to 40 LP
if they keep working for four to five
years and some people will even touch 50
LPA in us they start from 110 to 120k
per year for more experience of about
five years they can go to 200k as well
number four screen security auditor it
often gets overlooked by beginners
because it doesn't appeal to them and
doesn't Fascinate them but it is a very
responsible job and importantly
undoubtedly it's very important in
infosec Department we often need to
comply to certain government regulatory
policies when we deal with customer data
or public data such as Bank information
financial information pii or health
information so we need to comply and
follow certain standards so all the
infrastructure is regularly audited by
these teams for compliance and they are
also responsible for identification of
risk and issues they are also called
Risk Managers IIT Auditors or GRC so
they ultimately are responsible for
managing risk and compliance and of
course here as well you cannot join as a
fresher you need a responsible
experience but in India when you start
you can get 10 to 15 LPA and then the
growth is even better so after three to
four years even you can go up to 25 to
30 LPA in us the median is 120 to 130k
and if you work for three to four years
you can even go up to 180k number five
ciso Chief Information Security Officer
he is the backbone of the whole infosec
department you are in charge of the
infosight you are responsible for
managing everything and governing
everything to protect the IIT
infrastructure keeping it in compliance
and you manage all the security teams
under you so from auditing to budgeting
to developing infosec policies to
procurement everything it's a complete
leadership role it's an ultimate job
where you will need to have at least 10
to 15 years of experience in security
and also need to work as a manager for
five plus years in managing a security
team the salaries are immense of course
if you land it in India when they start
they can easily get up to 30 to 40 LPA
and they can even go to uh 70 to 80 LPA
if in some good companies and also five
plus years and in some top product based
companies in India they can even touch
100 LPA that is one crore and in U.S
it's even higher it starts from 300 to
350k and I'm not kidding but some offers
may even go up to 1 million USD per year
when you get experience for up to five
years so these are the top five cyber
security profiles you can apply now and
enjoy great packages and benefits but
again I'm not raising you to Cloud Nine
these packages are really very
subjective they will depend on a lot of
factors including company its size and
location I'm taking top mncs at the
reference number two your education
level number three job roles and
objectives number four Market Condition
it's not good right now of course
inflation and all number five your
performance so make sure you do your
research before applying and then you're
good to go in your career so I hope this
video gave you a right idea about the
benefits of a cyber security career and
what domains to choose and how to
proceed so all the best for your career
if you're planning for it cyber security
is one of the most popular career
options in IT industry but landing a job
in cyber security it's not that easy you
need to build a very strong resume with
very strong points including education
degree projects and certifications and
certifications are among the most
important criteria for any HR or a
manager to select the rightful candidate
for his most prestigious cyber security
job in big companies that will show the
right skills and expertise that you have
in this field so in this video I'm going
to talk about top 5 cyber security
certifications and my picks in order for
you to land a job in cyber security and
kick start your career in cyber security
so let's get started we keep hearing
this fact from many people in it that
cyber Security's biggest market right
now and it's only gonna boom but how
many people are getting supplied many
people are getting supplied but there is
an imbalance between the supply and
demand only because the supply that we
are getting is not rightfully skilled we
get a lot of candidates but are they
actually scaled toward the industry
wants according to a trusted survey
there will be million job opportunities
and openings by 2023 in India itself but
if you want to land a job and a good job
you need to be scaled to the core and
yeah I know you might have this question
that people ask me very often for
learning why do certifications why not
degrees why not colleges so the fact is
that College learning is not many times
not very often at par with what industry
demands there is a huge gap you may not
even be able to learn cyber security in
your college studies that's the truth
but in order to be good in this field
you need to be adaptive you need to
adapt at a pace that's not very often
kept up in college degree programs
syllabus don't very often change in this
degree programs while I do recommend
people to get at least one bachelor's
degree in CS or it but certifications
are the best way to boost your resume
and skills at the same time because they
take very less time they just focus on
one important Niche and go very deep
into it and they generally don't cost
you as much as a degree while degree can
cost you in lacks maybe 10 or more but a
certification will not cost you more
than a lakh or two and in a degree
you're taught many more things that you
don't even need in your career that you
want to pursue but the certification
will give you a path to follow in your
future so here are my picks for the top
five certifications in cyber security
that will give you a good position in
top company and your dream job so I'll
try to list them in order of the
experience level so the very first
certifications that you will and you
should do is ceh certified ethical
hacker this is the most basic course
that you can do that will build the very
fundamentals of you understanding how
attacks work how to find issues in
hacking a system this is the bare
minimum that everyone should do in order
to get started to get to know what this
field looks like so people new into this
field and just want to start their
career as a fresher I think this is one
of the best certifications to do I know
many people don't count it as worth
because it's lacking very Hands-On
training on real world scenarios but at
the end of the day it's a building block
and it gives you a mark of a certified
hacker and still HRS and India look for
this badge at the beer minimum in many
cases so you can be hard as a pen tester
or a security analyst and then break the
barrier of experience once and for all
and while you work you can focus on your
skill set and build and do more
certifications in the future and just
keep growing I know it's difficult to
manage skill development when you work
full time even I face the same
especially when you are doing it on your
own in self learning well well I know a
program that can make you a certified
ethical hacker while you study and guide
you on your learning I'm talking about
simply learns postgraduate program in
cyber security that is backed by top
expert study programs and faculty from
MIT schwasman College of computing and
even EC Council the program is an online
boot camp that runs for six months where
you will learn from industry experts how
to design build and Implement secure
systems at scale in large scale
organizations the course covers 20 of
the most popular and important security
domains and how to apply practices in
all of them and it is also aligned with
CompTIA Security Plus and will teach all
the standards covered there it will also
teach you how to develop a hacker
mindset identify and manage threads and
also the overall security posture of
large-scale organizations at the end of
The Learning you will get a Capstone
project where you will apply your
industry skills and you will get a
chance to Showcase your expertise to
Future employers you will also get
access to easy council's learning kit
and ceh V12 ilabs access for six months
along with an exam voucher which will
make you a certified ethical hacker
while you study and you will also get a
certificate from MIT shwasman College of
computing that is really valuable in
your resume so to be eligible for this
program you should have a bachelor's
degree with 50 or more of grades and you
need not have any programming experience
or any prior work experience so the
application for this program is really
very simple just go to the link in the
description click on the link review all
the program details click on apply Now
button on the page fill all the required
details asked from you and just submit
and wait for the reward back and I know
there are not many good programs out
there that can offer you so much at the
same time so don't think just go for it
the second third is com TR Security Plus
I know ceh is very popular in India but
if you talk about all around the world
CompTIA has done really good job in
establishing a foothold in this industry
this is also a basic certification made
for beginners which will teach you how
to secure network systems and
applications it's more on the security
side rather than the offensive side and
it's greatly aligned to Modern
Enterprise environment and in-demand
topics that ceh in some way fails to
cover including Cloud mobile and iot it
also covers governance risk and
compliance but yeah many people will
think that we still require practical
certifications but this is also a
theoretical certification that will have
90 Performance Based questions that are
not straightforward that will check your
concept overall what you have learned
but still is theoretical but if you want
to get a job in foreign in us or in UK
or anywhere around the world it's one of
the most recognized certifications out
there you can be hired as a security
engineer Cloud engineer ID auditor with
a very competitive package the third one
is gsec or giac certified security
engineer those who are already working
in Cooperative world may already know
that Sans is one of the top and one of
the best trainers in the world out there
and our personally done gpen and I know
that the knowledge that you get there is
nowhere else the top experts from each
field come out and teach and of course
that comes with a cost gsec is one of
the best selling certifications giac has
to offer it will teach you active
defense techniques network security
Cloud security incident response for n6
so it is one of the best certifications
for blow taming and the salary hike here
is real I can't tell you from my
personal experience if your base is low
you can easily get a 50 hike if your
base is high then you can easily get 30
40 hike but the catch here is I think
not many individuals can afford this
because the cost is really very high it
can even go to seven to eight lakhs for
a single training and certification so
you can only do that if your employer
sponsors you so if your employer has a
good bank balance and is good enough you
will want to do Sans training again and
again and again fourth one is seesaw or
certified information security auditor
risk and compliance are a very crucial
aspect of cyber security in today's
world especially if you are working in
an organization that deals with
sensitive customer data like Health
finance and government agencies so Asaka
comes up with this credential that will
focus on how to assess security
vulnerabilities how to report and
identify risk and manage compliance
according to various standards based on
the customer data in the Department
Industry they are in you must have heard
about some data standards like PC idss
ISO or HIPAA they all come around this
and this is one of the best
certifications that you can do for a
governance risk and compliance job or a
GRC or an auditor risk manager or a
cyber audit manager and the truth is
cyber Auditors are more respected than
pen testers because they are more wise
in decision making and they have a good
grip and understanding of how to assess
business risk but the certification
requires some prior experience in IIT
Assurance so if you want to switch into
auditing then you can definitely take
this the fifth one is cissp or sisp or
certified information system security
professional and this is no doubt one of
the best or maybe the best the most
prestigious certification in all of
infosec earning which you will be able
to run complex Security Programs and
manage them just what csos and managers
and directors do you will be capable of
running a complete cyber security
program right from design analysis is
implementation and managing a complete
info departments that just not includes
technical expertise but also management
expertise because that's what you learn
here and I can tell you the salaries
here are way more than what we desire
seriously it is meant for experienced
professionals with at least five years
of professional work experience in
infosec and have a bachelor's degree but
here if I talk about salaries they can
easily go to 50 LPA and even Beyond 50 L
for a CSO and you can even work as a
security consultant for World Stop
organizations with a package only above
competition so these are my top picks
for cyber security certifications in
2023 that you can do in order to get
started in a cyber security career or
even get eventually good and experienced
and switch over to different fields if
you are experienced so I hope you like
this video and you got something
valuable to learn from this and don't
forget to enroll into simply learns
postgraduate program in cyber security
that will give you industry guidance
skills and also certifications at the
same time and do share this video with
somebody that you feel might be
benefited from this just like you did so
that's all in this video from my side I
hope to see you again till then keep
learning and goodbye staying ahead in
your career requires continuous learning
and upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign